House of Representatives still has no
speaker but the important investigations
that began under speaker McCarthy they
are continuing house oversight uh
committee chairman James comr has
released new evidence today in his
investigation into the Biden family
Syndicate their business dealings and
this is a bombshell take a look at this
that is a check from Jim Biden that is
Joe Biden's brother to Joe for a
whopping
$200,000 and this very check was written
on the exact same day that Jim allegedly
got a quote loan from a failing Hospital
company for the exact same amount of
money we did reach out to the parties
involved for comment and shockingly we
didn't hear back but clearly this news
is creating some Panic inside the Biden
White House tonight and one of Biden's
press underlings rushed to make sure
that everybody knows the cck clearly
says was a loan repayment from Jim to
Joe but if that's true it unlocks a
whole new host of questions why did Joe
loan Jim 200 Grand in the first place
question two how did Joe uh admittedly
one of the poorest members of the Senate
a career public servant how did he have
and was able to how was he able to
afford to give that amount of money to
his brother and why did Jim need to be
paid by someone else before he could
repay Joe he with the details house
oversight and accountability committee
chair James comr is with us uh and by
the way correct me if I'm wrong and
maybe I'm jumping ahead uh you have
other new evidence that we expect next
week that'll show something
similar yeah we've uh we found a lot of
suspicious checks that uh the brother
was involved in and Joe was a
beneficiary of and we're going to talk
about that uh as we move on but what
we're doing is we're tracing the money
Sean it's not just that they got a
$200,000 payment that Joe Biden received
a $200,000 pay it's where the money came
from and the money came from Jim B
where he influence pedal to a company in
the United States that he went and said
that he could help through his brother's
contacts get capital from from the
Middle East so he convinced this company
to give him $600,000 and they did it in
increments the last increment was
$200,000 that $200,000 then went to Jim
Biden's personal account and it was a
loan according to uh the way Jim Biden
deposit and then he wrote on the same
day a check to Joe Biden for a loan
repayment now they're playing the loan
card a lot remember the $250,000 wire
that we identified three weeks ago that
came from China the hunter Biden that
was addressed to Joe Biden's house the
White House said that was a loan too and
Sean what you're going to be hearing out
of the White House over the next few
weeks is loan loan loan and look even if
Joe Biden did give his brother alone
which I don't believe he did the fact
that that his brother defrauded a
company that is now bankrupt and all the
creditors lost all their money that they
invested in this or loan to this healthc
care company but Joe Biden got $200,000
from it before they went bankrupt all
because Jim Biden was selling the brand
was selling the Biden name and convinced
people to pay in money in exchange for
favors from Joe Biden wouldn't you have
to have a record of when you gave the
loan and wouldn't that bank record exist
as well have you been able to find that
we well we just F announced a check
today and we've asked the White House to
produce
documentation of the loan the terms of
the loan and and we also want to know
from Joe Biden was he aware when he took
that
$200,000 that it came from a company his
brother defrauded in the name of Joe
Biden that Joe Biden could come in and
save the day through his contacts in the
Middle East Sean that that's where this
influence pedaling scheme came we've
talked about China Romania Russia
Ukraine now we're talking about the
Middle East we've talked about Hunter
Biden now we're on to Jim Biden we've
been following the money we're going to
continue to follow the money but more
and more suspicious activity is popping
up everywhere to the tunes of millions
and millions of dollars from the Biden
family and now we have evidence that Joe
Biden benefited directly from this if if
his brother hadn't defrauded that
company through the influence in scheme
he never could have paid Joe Biden back
that $200,000 assuming Joe Biden really
loaned him $200,000 which I'm not
convinced that he did would it be a fair
assessment in the next couple of week
there'll be a cascading amount of
devastating evidence like this that
proves that uh by following the money
that everything Joe Biden said about his
involvement in all of this is false is
that a fair statement look I I think we
continue to produce evidence I think
we've already produced
a lot of evidence but the media says
well you got to have a payment to Joe
well here we go here's the first payment
to Joe stay tuned Sean stay tuned all
right Congressman James comr we thank
you this Friday night hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else